what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with weapons of Vengeance part
of the fall of X event and we are
picking up with the character of bran
now for those of you guys who are
following this story you know that it
jumps back and forth between the past
and the present and all we really know
is that years ago bran was introduced to
us as a kid who was possessed by some
kind of a demon and that in the modern
era he's traveling around the world and
killing mutants wherever he finds them
so jumping back to the past what we end
up doing is picking up with Bram where
he's brought to really like an old folks
home right hospice and home care and
what we find out here is that this demon
kind of has to feed if it doesn't it'll
just simply seize control of Bram and
Bram will just attack whoever happens to
be in sight regardless of the
circumstance so it's just kind of
letting the Beast loose for a moment and
it's pretty dark because what ends up
happening is this kind of adopted mom if
you want to call her that when she gets
there they pay a guy under the table and
this kid in turn just like destroys this
old lady right the Beast comes out just
completely annihilates her and that's it
now one of the interesting things about
this and it wasn't somebody that's
really been explored until now Bram
doesn't like this life he doesn't like
being possessed by this demon this this
kind of entity we sort of knew that to a
degree but we didn't really know how far
reaching it was obviously this would
have some kind of an impact on a younger
kid like this but then you switch over
to Wolverine and Ghost Rider right now
of course these two are just flying out
right they're just hauling over to like
the devil's Racing Ground basically is
what it is but they're going there to
find what is in effect this kind of
demonic process that deals with the
weapons plus program now one of the
things we talked about in the previous
video and I think it's worth reiterating
here weapons plus has a long history a
lot of people associate it specifically
wolf Wolverine but it's much bigger than
that right weapons Plus at least weapon
one was Captain America if Grant
Morrison's new X-Men is to be believed
and then you had just different programs
that came after that that focus on
creating like other super soldiers
following the perceived death of Steve
Rogers at the end of World War II
Wolverine was just the 10th iteration of
that but you've also got Frank Simpson
right then you've got like the Stepford
cacus who are like clones of Emma Frost
you've got Phantom X you have all these
different characters that are out there
the recreation or the restructuring of
weapons Plus at least as it's being used
here it's combining demonic energy with
beings who are out there that can be
used to basically create super soldiers
that have demonic power but like so many
organizations out there this one is
again out for the mutant population and
that's one of the things that was
largely built on with the work of really
Jonathan Hickman and like the
introduction of orcas the anti-mutant
organization the X-Men taking off to
Cocoa they made a lot of enemies and
there's a lot of groups out there that
have inviting their time and waiting for
a chance to basically destroy the mutant
population and while orcas is
responsible for the brunt of their
seeming Annihilation although again
they're not all dead that it's really
kind of cleanup Duty for the smaller
organization that are out there right
they see it as their time to shine and
so at that point this focuses on the
Learned arrival that Wolverine and
Johnny Blaze are coming and what you
have here is a guy named father Pike and
literally it's just kind of like these
guys are on their way father Pike
doesn't care too much about Johnny Blaze
the person he's after is Wolverine so
again we don't really know how far
reaching this goes with this guy but it
is cool and so at that point you switch
over to Jeff Bannister who was
introduced in the Wolverine Comics as
being what's basically Wolverine's
contact in the CIA as well as a great
friend the issue is he's been doing some
kind of Recon work on the side focusing
a lot on like demonic stories and
information and so on and so forth but
what he was warned about by Johnny Blaze
and really The Ghost Writer was if you
stare into the abyss the abyss will
stare back do not get too deep into all
of this research because you're talking
about demonic stuff right it doesn't
just require you to be messing with
tarot cards in the real life right this
transfers its energy and its Essence
through a variety of different methods
different mediums and one of these can
be through computers and so steering
into this stuff too much suddenly he's
met by not really possession but he's
influenced by the powers of hell now
it's one of the things I love about how
this is done because when you look at
Marvel much like DC there are two sides
of it right you have like the X-Men The
Avengers Fantastic Four the crazy
adventure wonky stories Spider-Man that
you normally get with like traditional
superhero stuff once you start getting
into Ghost Rider once you start getting
into man thing you start getting into
Doctor Strange to a degree and Wolverine
depending on who's writing the story
you'll get into this whole other Mythos
right where you deal with guys like
Mephisto and so on and so forth just
like Damon halstrom these demonic beings
and the power they possess and so where
Jeff Bannister is infected by this and
is in fact actually driven to like stab
himself right by all these different
things that Talia Warroad breaks into
the scene now Talia was introduced in
The Ghost Writer comic books and she was
at least an agent for the FBI kind of
working for like their Supernatural
division ultimately they parted ways but
she has kind of been like the sidekick
so to speak and I use that term loosely
for lack of a better word uh but she's
been a kind of sidekick for Johnny Blaze
joining him on his journey as he's
trying to destroy all the different
demons that exist out there in the world
that basically rose up during his
absence but it is cool to see that she's
involved here and in fact she even gives
Jeff Bannister a little bit of a kind of
concoction that helps to keep these
demonic forces at Bay basically pushing
back prevent him from being possessed
and then she kind of warns them like do
not delve too deep into this stuff right
you're like an amateur here you don't
know what you're getting into who knows
what you could unleash out here into the
world it's not for the faint of heart
right so you don't really get a whole
lot with her it's really her just kind
of issuing a warning and then seemingly
sticking around but you transition to
Wolverine and Johnny Blaze once they get
into the facility itself and what they
find here is that unlike in years past
when weapons plus just would modify
human beings or they would turn somebody
like Wade Wilson into what would
basically become Deadpool you know so on
and so forth that what you have going on
is again them trying to create demon
beings right demonic Monsters by
basically restructuring human DNA and so
on and so forth it doesn't really seem
to work but as they're making their way
through here suddenly they're hit by the
helmets of weapons plus these are
basically training helmets they would
throw them on the heads of people who
were basically being subjected to like
mental conditioning that's why Wolverine
says like not again because it's what
they did to him when he was part of
weapons plus it's a way to shut their
minds down but also force them to see
things that aren't there and so on and
so forth and so what we end up doing is
picking up with Bram in the weapons plus
laboratory in the here and now and he's
still much older and he still shuns his
possession here not only that we
actually get a name for the being that
he's possessed by which is now bhagra
ghoul is is wholly introduced into this
as far as I'm aware there's never really
been a presence for his character in
Marvel Comics before my initial thought
is that it was demon bear right like
they look almost exactly alike it seems
like bugger rule manifests more as a
bear than anything else but it may just
be because of the kind of Terror that it
instills in humans who see it we don't
really know the whole motivation but
father Pike and speaking to Bram kind of
refers to this as a bit of a gift right
Bram refers to it as a curse and has for
the longest time and even father Pike
says we gave you the opportunity to be
part of an army you have done what we
asked of you but only with the greatest
reluctance so we have enlisted a more
worthy Soldier to take your place now
where Bram recognizes Wolverine if for
no other reason than the encounter that
they had when he was younger father Pike
talks about how Wolverine has a
reputation but he doesn't really
understand the relationship between Bram
and Wolverine which is to say they know
each other or at least they've met at
some point in time but what they do here
is they create a kind of process to
allow this demonic transference and it's
one of those things where when Bram asks
like will I be myself again the response
of Father Pike is there will be no more
pain that I can promise right so
seemingly they're going to kill Bram off
guys like Father Pike don't make
statements like that unless something
nefarious is going to come out of it and
so following that Wolverine kind of
Muses to himself about his own Berserker
rage with his mind kind of being shut
down what it looks like is he's
consciously aware of what's going on but
he's there and not there at the same
time and so he says like Johnny talked
to me about what it feels like when the
Ghost Rider takes over he says it's like
watching a horror movie on a top volume
TV that's plugged into your skull I can
relate when rage finds me I become
someone else sometimes breathing heavy
I'll take in the wreckage all around me
the blood dripping from my claws and
hardly know how it happened I feel the
same potential for Unchained violence
now I'm here but I'm not here they're
controlling me and soon that demon that
Stitcher that bhagwar ghoul or whatever
the hell is called will control me so
what wolverine is talking about here is
he's talking about his Berserker rage
right that whenever Wolverine finds
himself in a heightened stated arrest
and loses control quote unquote his
Madness takes over he becomes an animal
and it's the reason why whenever
Wolverine goes into a Berserker rage and
the X-Men realize what's happening
unless someone like Xavier or Jean
Gray's there they can use their
telepathy to like calm him down
everybody gives him a wide berth because
he does not differentiate between Friend
or Foe and so following this father Pike
basically commences with the merging of
these two guys right or at least passing
the demon entity from one to the other
and following that Wolverine becomes the
hell of a rain right literally a
demonically possessed Wolverine he says
my veins burn like channels of lava I
feel Jaws gobbling the inside and and
the outside of me but somehow I managed
to break free for One Last Stand before
bhagra ghoul stitches himself onto me
and I become hellvarine right possessed
by a demon and he looks amazing and so
simply just following orders what ends
up happening is he is sent by father
Pike out into the world to kill every
mutant he can possibly find five mutants
are detected within 159 miles something
to understand here this is not the first
time that happened and Wolverine
possessed by a demon is more than enough
to not only Wipe Out the entirety of the
remaining mutants on Earth outside of
some crazy level reality Warfare but is
also capable of wiping out most all
superheroes on Earth this guy could kill
the world we know because he did it at
one point in time in Marvel Comics with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end if you need to get caught
up on weapons of Vengeance make sure you
click this link to the playlist and I
will catch you all later
peace